this is star clunkers I'm David
Grinspoon astrobiologist I go on Twitter
as dr. funky spoon now some people have
asked me if your name is David Grinspoon
why are you on Twitter is dr. funky
spoon and all I can say to that is like
[Music]
[Applause]
understand alright where were we
we're going to do yeah that's right
we're on Startalk Allstars yeah I'm
David Grinspoon and I'm with my awesome
co-host mr. Chuck nine a man how are you
tell us what's going on Chuck well you
know we're doing some cosmic queries
here and first of all thank you for
thank you for the blues riff yeah well
there's a lot more where that came from
oh well that's cool well you know we're
talking about the virtual universe and
the man sitting next to me it's pretty
much responsible for the virtual
universe itself yeah we have we're so
happy so lucky to have with us an old
friend and a genius of science
communication Carter Emer
who is the get this the director of
Astro visualization at the American
Museum of Natural History how's it going
Carter thanks for joining us yeah well
here's the cool thing about having
Carter here is when I saw that we were
going to do a cosmic queries for Astro
visualization and you know cosmic
queries is where we take questions from
all over the Internet and whatever
incarnation where we exist as Startalk
and our fans ask us things that they
want to know and I saw that that's what
we were going to be talking about and
the first question I had was what the
hell is Astro visualization because I
had never heard of it before and of
course I had to go do some research but
it Carter this is fascinating stuff
explain yourself sir exactly well
essentially it's a way using the modern
technology
and display data visualization hooked
into immersive theater which the
planetarium has always been as a
recreational night sky but now with
video control controlled by computers
essentially you're staring up into your
entire visible field a construction of
the universe's best that we know of in
other words to visualize essentially
that information to move through it and
do that accurately and also through
simulations of astrophysics the talk
about the behavior or the simulate try
to simulate the behavior of the universe
across time from what I've seen that you
have done I mean it kind of would it'd
be kind of weird or crazy to call it
kind of like a google maps of the
universe that's exactly what it
okay good no cool out so I'm not I am
NOT crazy
you may be crazy but you've got that one
just right well you know what that's you
know what that's probably more the case
David is that I am still crazy but even
a broken clock is Right twice a day
so yeah I mean now here's one of the
things and we're going to get into the
questions the cosmic queries you know as
we talk about it but when you the Google
Maps of the universe when I saw your
your TED talk and I saw your awesome
display of this the the thing that got
me was just like Google Maps and you
know Google Maps when they map an area
they send the Google Maps car that we
all know is the big car with the dome on
it and it's got all the cameras and it's
taking a 360 degree view of everything
that's happening all around okay so now
in your presentation you take us outside
of this I'll call it the space-time
containment and you're showing the
universe as contained in this bubble so
now how one how do you do that to how
accurate would that be or three is that
an extrapolation that is more
theoretical well the thing is we can we
can plot distances and so if we know
distances and we know where they are
sort of spherically around us sort of
you know like the old planetarium that's
a dome of stars over our head right
that's that's essentially what the sky
looks like as long as we know distances
to you know the solar system objects of
course they move but then stars which
are also everything's in motion but
moving slower and then two galaxies even
farther away that really the confluence
of these technologies and computer speed
essentially which was really enabled all
of this so from around the term of the
turn of the millennium we're all the
sort of came together we were a
millennium project and rebuilding the
venerable Hayden Planetarium which
opened in 1935 is that the accuracy is
there in some cases and certain
interactive shows not so much our movies
that we tend to produce is that we can
show uncertainty and other ways in which
you that uncertainty shows itself in so
far as how we measure distances and so
we can talk about that accuracy and
however as you go farther and farther
out you're dominated more and more by
this look-back time essentially I mean
we see the Sun eight minutes in the past
right and but the farthest you know sort
of utterance of the universe so far this
radiation that we can see essentially
because behind everything it permeates
us moving through us right now right
just microwave back right away it feels
really good I'm just saying like it yeah
digging on it right now for that whole
vibration of MS which you even even the
low ebb but but but it's exactly we are
soaking in it and but the odd thing is
is we know the universe is larger than
that visible bubble that we see because
what we're seeing is some people call it
the world picture as opposed the world
map and the world pictures essentially
oh I take a picture I see the Sun eight
minutes in the past and say Jupiter's
beyond that I see Jupiter maybe you know
an hour in the past or something like
this but that's that's just the reality
of light traveling at a fixed speed but
I love the fact that you represent the
uncertainty too because science is not
all just about what we know and some of
the best science communication also
emphasizes what we don't know because
that's what
cool when there's still a puzzle so I
love that you can include that and
another really cool thing about what
Carter does is that his database is
always changing when we learn something
new the New Horizons mission to Pluto
Carter and I did actually a interactive
event multi-location event while that
was happening and what is so cool is
that as soon as we have the new pictures
on the ground I mean that that's our
Google car out in the Kuiper belt now as
soon as they have the new pictures on
the ground Carter can put that in his
database and now you go to his show and
instead of just this fuzzy blob with the
uncertainty of we have no idea now it's
these high-resolution pictures because
he cannot insert that and improve his
database as we learn more
so now as images come in and what you
just said so your your visualization and
your whatever you know algorithms and
you know the programs that you're using
to make this happen so they would have
to be dynamic in order to receive all
this new information and change along
with everything that's happening yes so
as as as pictures come in the idea is to
be able to plot them not only just to
show the sort of updated map so for
example but the team of New Horizons
have now synthesized and put together a
very nice sort of global map that you
can put on the ball and look at it study
it fantastic one of the other aspects of
the visualization that we were
attempting to show and that David and
other mission scientists during the
event we're actually there to comment on
this we did a global broadcast called
breakfast with Pluto which we captures
on YouTube if you look I went to one of
those on a Disney cruise not that we got
this with Pluto I got a jungle right I
was awesome yeah it was probably similar
very different right but but but but the
point was to actually show a kind of
engineering visualization to actually
show the very complicated set of tasks
that the spacecraft had to do and
because in that we're showing the
prowess of the ability by humans to
actually think this up plan this and
then carry this off there was criticism
of during the time during the actual
encounter that there was nothing to see
because we didn't have
recent images and I would take the
counter-argument that we could actually
show the exact planned because we
weren't sure whether it was actually
happening or not because the spacecraft
went completely into action mode and was
not in connection it was not in direct
communication with the earth I know if
it was it takes four and a half hours to
learn if the spacecrafts okay writes
right right so we were looking at the
planned sequence of observations and so
they're different instruments and they
make and they're depicted in different
ways and in which that imaging campaign
is going across Pluto in the case of the
highest resolution images because
there's a set field of view of the
camera effectively that you see more by
putting the camera closer to the object
and that's what was happening we're
streaming past Pluto and about 14
kilometres a second so it's like seven
miles a second we're passing Pluto so
very fast it's smaller than our moon and
so we got about a distance of one earth
on diameter away from it and so we're in
really close and you could see those
pictures being laid down about once
every second you're coming in and that's
something to celebrate is this human
ingenuity later we get the pictures back
in fact all the data coming back from
that mission takes 16 months so over a
year of all the stuff coming back we're
still pictures coming in we swap in we
can update the visualization so we can
effectively ride along and the sort of
simulation of this I liken it to just a
sort of updated and computerized version
and rendering of what we had back in the
Apollo program when we launched to the
moon that rocket would go out of sight
of the cameras and then they would go to
like artwork right I'm showing like it's
dropping a stage and would say
simulation looks like of course it is
going to get to drawing okay in history
are seeing the computerized
visualization of of that prowess of
having to calculate all at which the the
team had to do and carry off and they
practiced it two times before we
actually got to Pluto which is amazing
yeah it was really cool and it probably
is the best way to get a sense of what
the encounter was really like in real
time for the spacecraft and for the
people involved so it
on line as Carter mentioned check it out
it's called breakfast at Pluto and you
can you can look at it maybe we should
go to some of our cosmic queries now and
absolutely see what our listeners want
to know about Astro visualization all
right all right
so this is from a Sonja wing yeah swing
yeah it's kind of a cool name Sonya swen
yeah so Leah wrote in to start off where
do net and said how do you feel about
white hole theory in relation to
gravitational waves black holes and dark
matter I'm not sure how that relates to
visualization but is there a there few
things to say about that okay I think
the white hole theory if I write if I
think that rings at all but I'd like the
auditors dancing and not breaking it
down this way people we're not going
like that this is all science has
nothing to do so I started taking
classes the planetarium in the 1970s I
was like 11 years old
and those are the black holes and then
the white hole theory was we saw quasars
and there are these very very powerful
sources we now seem to understand that
those are actually black holes if you
pour some gas on them so if you got some
gas and poured on a black hole it swirls
around creates this accretion disk is it
extremely bright and that these
supermassive black holes caused by sort
of collisions or accretion of black
holes tends to happen on the center of
galaxies okay fine so we saw these
quasars and we had this theory of black
holes
we saw some x-rays and the constellation
Cygnus which is a summer constellation
the Northern Hemisphere and so we're
this idea was maybe because black holes
Bend space so much that maybe that the
stuff that goes into black holes comes
out at a white hole okay I think that's
been superseded as we understood the
processes of the astrophysics around
black holes better but what I would I
would I would love to see this be the
case but insofar as just black holes are
kind of a natural prize
gravitational collapse okay after it's
been held up by essentially the nucleo
synthetic chain of what star does and
was in its core is that these black
holes degenerate mass they come together
and they arm notions of space and time
break down in black and also our
understanding of the beginning of the
universe is fuzzy because where did this
come from we know that it started at a
certain time but we can't really
understand the conditions from which
they come so if black holes which are
just a natural consequence of what we
have in our universe right are the
beginnings of new universes and that
that you know if we were you know
generated in some other it's very much
like you know sort of Brahma waking up
it is very much like a Hindu scriptures
so far as this repeated notion of an
engaged University the way yeah one so
so anyway my friend late arthur c clarke
like to say about gamma-ray bursts or
another very high energy events visited
him in 2002 he said well how the hulk
came into being but he asked me what do
you think of gamma-ray bursts right I
said well I don't know Arthur what do
you think it goes I hope they're not
industrial accidents yeah you would say
that by that by the way the actual
question from from the listener was how
do you feel about the theory yeah yeah I
feel pretty good about it
I mean I don't know if it's if it's
correct but but but I like it but but
there's also the question about dark
matter but to bring it back just for a
second back to a strobe visualization I
imagine a challenging part of what you
do there's one thing showing what things
look like what we could actually see
with our eyes here's what Buddha would
like look like if you were flying past
it but then there's this whole other set
of phenomena that we could never see
with our eyes that you can bring to
light and I think a black hole must be a
good example of that you can show ways
to to visualize things that we would
never actually visualize with it with or
with him are enough and there are two
really good examples of black hole the
visualization one was done by the Denver
Museum of Nature and Science and is at
Hamilton your colleague or former
colleague at the University of Colorado
Alexander Hamilton for Hamilton
dr. Hamilton and they
did he he did sort of a sabbatical
working with them on the visualization
it's very abstract it's very fantastical
but it was accurate and then also in
interstellar where they worked on the
visualization of the effects as we can
calculate that's around a black hole
yeah one of the times when Hollywood
actually made an effort to run things
the way it really is as opposed to just
making it look cool and so there's
anything wrong with that so well and and
but the the effort to try to really
calculate what one would see which is
now we're capable of doing that because
we have greater and greater computing
capabilities that our eye fingertips is
a worthy effort because you know what
these things look like are are a great
interest to everyone and so when you're
making these simulations and you're
taking into account all the data that is
there is it something where you theorize
mathematically along different tangents
and then you create each one of those or
is it you theorize a most likely case
scenario and then you visualize that
when we do our show productions which
will focus on particular sort of
fundamental aspects of astrophysics or
the known universe we had a show on
cosmic collisions we had another show
about the ins you know what makes stars
work and then we have a show dark
universes which is about what we know
about the universe is that our curators
part of the Rose Center for Earth and
space or Department of astrophysics they
decide amongst their colleagues what the
what the world's leading research is we
we actually convene a scientific
symposium at the beginning of any one of
these show production process and and so
that we identify who will be the
consultants for the project but also who
are the data providers a simulation sort
of the best sort of simulations that
around the table we discuss who is
likely to have that best simulation in
some cases it's it's a simulation that
that will fit both that something is
available it's available in the right
amount
time we're in some cases we've actually
sort of pushed what was being calculated
so that we would have a high quality
product to visualize so under I'm sorry
we're going to drive a take a little
break here you are listening to Startalk
all-stars and we'll be back shortly this
is Startalk Allstars
I'm David Grinspoon and we're here with
Chuck nice and Carter Emmert yes Carter
the actual is a astro visualization guru
if I can call you that from the American
Museum of Natural History Carter was
just telling us about all the brain
power that goes into producing one of
the planetarium shows you may go there
and just think it looked neat and it's
fun but he was just telling us there's
this big gathering of the Nerds that
they convene where all the scientists
get together and talk about the latest
theories and they decide what to show
scientifically in all of their shows the
cool thing is for those of you who don't
have the benefit of watching us on video
you'll just listen to the podcast the
cool thing about Carter is that he's
producing these shows that visualize the
universe but he looks like he should be
producing a show that visualizes the
Grateful Dead so you know it's good you
know it's good I think I was I was
thinking more Burning Man
everything react we did take the
visualization out the Burning Man vision
for see it looks like he just stepped
off the playa and into the universe all
right we're all doing that that's all in
the universe all right but people are
right over there well let's burn right
along here and get back to cosmic
queries and Chuck why don't you give us
another question all right how about
this let's go to a patreon patron a
question and this is from Dillon
Hallahan who supports us on patreon of
which you can do as well and by doing so
you will be allowed to have priority
given to your particular enquiries so
just keep that in mind
Dillon would like to know this are there
any ways we can create a virtual
singularity where we can represent the
beginning Dillon is coming to us from
Washington Township in New Jersey
so would we be able is there enough
information about you know and of course
the background radiation is always there
and it's always happening but the event
itself the singularity itself could we
do we have enough information to
recreate a visual representation of that
singularity to some degree I would say a
little bit after me on the universe
starts to expand yeah so we can't get
the birth but we could maybe get but a
slap on the ass the baby slap on the ass
we could get but we couldn't get the
actual you know much you get that first
cry on the first try but not the actual
you know it's crowning like that that
alright I think we are you man totally
freaking Connor out with my description
of the birth of the universe flow we we
don't know okay why we don't know we can
serve describe what what and back to a
certain point but so that very beginning
is is something that we extrapolate our
physics by the point of a greatest
pressure and temperatures that and then
we test this and the largest you know
atom smashers in the war hold and like
it's CERN and and so forth to really
kind of look at what those conditions
are right wait a mystery when you try to
go all of all the way by that that's
right first tiny fraction of a second
right very hard to get information so
we're left with theory and there is of
course like to argue with one another
and then invent and then looking at how
the universe expands and that we can
track that to some degree and and that's
a visualization of that by tamil and his
visualizer Ralph Caylor is in dark
universe it becomes seen on so sweet
evolution of essentially structure over
time the universe is expanding but
locally it's contracting the gives of
gravity and so you end up with this
giant sort of web this cosmic web which
we actually observe you can even a small
telescope you can go out I grew up in
New Jersey and you could look up and the
constellation Virgo it's going to tell
the Virgo
you see you see galaxies even even a
small telescope so you're looking at a
local area of downtown which we are not
and in the same way that we're sort of
in the suburbs of the galaxy is probably
a good thing it's a good place to raise
the kids but I was so uptight here on
earth because we're living in the suburb
of the galaxy well it's a little more
stable than the raucous ride in the
middle of any peak you say when we grow
up we can go downtown town right the
center of the galaxy exactly the really
good radiation I'm not by yourself and
not unaccompanied young man and I mean
that supercool well you know that's a
great great answer man that is great
answer let us take another question
and I like this one from Jonathan
gallant from Facebook and he comes to us
from Edmonton up in the great light way
so this is what he says how far away
from a Star Trek like stellar
cartography room or better known as a
holodeck Thank You Jonathan for getting
so technical are we to creating
something like that so you know man in
other words that I'm done it what oh
that's a great question and it's in fact
exam I've what one of it one of the
great things about being Carter's friend
in addition to his colleague is that
sometimes he'll he'll take some of us
after hours into and he basically calls
it his spaceship and he's even called it
his holodeck and it's it is that is what
you have you have a hollow to it so I
kind of like to make a joke is if you
can if you have a holodeck then you
don't need to Starship nobody find my so
true yeah but in a way that's really
true and that's that's what that's what
the job is about so you you know what
constitutes a holiday well for the
uninitiated to give you sorry a virtual
really uninitiated okay which is the
room they can go in and basically
simulate any sensory experience sure
sure and so I say okay Carter's almost
there we're almost there
visually it's an immersion in the in the
data and then the in the map
essentially so if you look at the
traditional planetarium it stars on the
ceiling you point out the Big Dipper and
Orion an emotion of this is sort of a
diurnal motion the sky the stars rise
and set carries the Sun along with a
moon and you know the phases of the
movement of the planets and all that and
that's our view from from the earth it's
amazing that the ancients were able to
sort of figure out at all that we go
around the Sun because the Sun obviously
goes around us every day you know and
the planets go around and that we live
in a broader geography called the galaxy
and then the galaxies just one of many
ok so we we sort of have all that
information so plotting it accurately
and moving out into the data and moving
through it is that you see at 3
dimensionally so you feel as though
you're in the presence of you are you're
in the presence of that data and that's
what we do so the dome is the immersive
theater and it surrounds us and then we
can move out we can move away from the
earth we can fly over the surface of
planets that we have information for
Mars we have tremendous information for
moon mercury well certainly our own
planet and Mars is something that's very
interesting because we have this
tremendous campaign in support of
eventually humans going there and so
forth but that we have a six terabyte
data set that you can fly over the big
laptop route of Mars it's essentially
it's about three quarters of Mars down
to the size of a two-car garage six
meters Wow and we can fly for hours over
just one section of the canyon and you
get lost and you can also go to boring
parts of Mars you can work flat but the
thing is is the whoring part of Mars
well there are adjectives surprise a lot
of it you put the butcher list coming
back to the holodeck is just this notion
that you know we have a tremendous
tremendous mountain of data that's on
the ground it's in what NASA's planetary
data service the PDS and it's a matter
of taking that information
contextualizing it I've had an army of
high-school students who have taken
basically the stereo images from the
micro imager
on the arm of the the solar-powered
Rovers is a spirit and opportunity and
opportunity opportunity still going
we're not messing with the Curiosity
rover data yet because it tends to be
under scientific embargo but we get
you're able to take the dual images and
use data or use software from NASA to
synthesize that into accurate 3d models
and so and then we have to contextualize
where they are but in that sense we're
essentially looking so close not only
like three centimeters so just over an
inch of the time these tiny little
targets on Mars you can see all this
incredible detail on a rock on a planet
that no one's been to right this is this
is what NASA does is it reaches out
there and other and the European Space
Agency the space agencies the world
we're going to these other places and
we're bringing this back it's our job
and obligation to put that into a
context that everyone can see now let me
tell you I just like that that you what
you just described really is like being
there in a much more fundamental way
than a planetarium show used to be
correct that leads me to want to ask you
a question that's slightly more
philosophical which is I mean you and I
both are children of Apollo we grew up
dreaming about space and going into
space in 2001 a Space Odyssey and that
was going to be the future in our life
and neither one of us has gotten to go
into space yet we're getting a little
bit older who knows what's going to
happen I'll join me out of the show
fellows and I ya know some for you got
excellent look forward to that but but I
guess what I want to know is on the
other hand you've gotten more and more
into this visualization and this this
ability to go there in this way that is
not quite being their bodily but it's
more being there than just looking at
pictures and I've heard you say things
like well we don't need a spacecraft
because we go to holodeck and you're
kind of joking but I also get the sense
that there's a way in which maybe you
feel that this is a valid way for human
beings to experience space and we can
send our unmanned spacecraft there are
unsound
it's paced craft or not just unmanned or
unwilling to so let's say unpiloted but
we can send our spacecraft there and
they gather the data
really good data and then we visualize
it and it's as if we're going there but
we don't need to send our frail human
bodies there so do you feel like that is
in a way the space exploration of the
future to some degree yes and especially
when you get beyond the solar system
because as New Horizons you and I were
at the launch in 2006 and then we were
together again but virtually sort of on
this virtual networking but then with
the simulation of seeing exactly what
was happening and that you know that's
amazing that we got a spacecraft out
there in ten years but when you leave
interstellar wise and you look and and
if you want to explore in that sense
it's going to be a long time before
perhaps were able to ever do that and so
this information once again that's on
the ground that just needs to be put
into a system like this to be visualized
is a valid way of exploring at many
different scales and to see the
beautiful images say of you know like
the plethora of images from from now 25
years of the Hubble Space Telescope that
sort of thing is is that we can see this
amazing work but we see it contextually
and how that fits into the rest of the
bigger picture it changed how you feel
about wanting to go to Mars is it enough
it has that enough for you
today now you don't have to go that well
well the thing is that my to go more you
want to go lay I have to I have to look
at this in my own lifetime
it's just that yes I was eight years old
we walked on the moon
I could extrapolate and say well when
we're we have a Mars mission maybe I
could I could be there but I'm not going
to go to Mars but the thing is is that
my job means that we really have to take
that amazing amount of information that
we have these incredible vistas that we
can see of these other planets and put
that together for everyone to appreciate
and see because not everybody is going
to go to Mars some people probably will
I think we're helping to train these
these young minds to sort of desire that
perhaps they see it they want to go I
totally understand that but this is
valid experience of it's closer to the
science and how science has to explore
it has to look at these analog
and and things like this pick out these
details this fine sifting we can we can
sort of cut through all of that and
present that directly to the public and
make them amazed at at this tremendous
amount that we have gathered and we have
here that just is not being
contextualized properly yeah percent is
Delta between the actual experience and
experiencing virtually the going to Mars
like as this technology gets as this
technology grows I'm so sorry
as it grows the closer we get to being
able to send somebody to Mars how much
closer will that be to just experience
to get here on earth well the thing is
we only have about 30 seconds obviously
we walked on the moon and you know
synthesizing what we can to the moon
which is something we're looking at
doing it's not the same as being here of
course but it's also one that allows us
to pause and reflect and really think
about these artists things rather than
being on this timescale times schedule
like the Apollo astronauts were go here
come back and a lot more people can do
it and they don't fry their gonads with
space radiation so there's that to be
sad radiation is a big big issue on that
point if we're going to take a little
break here you're listening to Startalk
Allstars and we'll be back shortly
hello this is Startalk Allstars
I'm David Grinspoon sometimes known on
Twitter is dr. funky spoon and I'm here
with Chuck nice lad on Twitter as Chuck
nice comment that is correct and our
very special guest
Carter Emmert on Twitter as explored the
universe tour the tour of the University
or or the universe and by the way you
may wonder what a self-respecting
Startalk host is doing with this piece
of technology I not only play with
scientific instruments sometimes I play
with musical instruments and actually
I've got a little song that the Chuck
nice wrote for me yeah and you know
biology plan I saw that you you know you
play with that house band of the
universe and other different groups and
I was like hey would it be kind of cool
if you did a little something called the
astrobiologist blues and I really
appreciate you indulging me by taking my
stupid little words and put some music
to it yeah we're gonna we're going to
give that a try I mean you know to me
science music it's all waves right
interacting with the different forms of
radiation in the universe and so yeah I
play in this group called the house band
of the universe check us out online we
play in planetarium sometimes a lot of
fun but but right now let's get back to
let's get back to enough about sound
let's get back to vision we're talking
about astral visualization here with our
guest
Carter Emmer and we're doing cosmic
queries so Chuck what other questions do
we have from listeners about Astro
visualization oh man let's let's get
back to the cosmic queries and hmm Lenny
wax deck from Twitter at Lenny be big
wad oh that's that's weird Lenny Lenny
was know this little virtual reality
helped people truly connect with the
cosmos do you see a greater connection
when you when you watch people in this
immersive
the question yes and that is that you
know we walk down the street we don't
really encounter aspects of the
universe's are there right I like to say
that people I'm sort of a Bugs Bunny
view of the universe like all that stuff
that's up there and they know Saturn's
up there's got the ring you know and you
know but it's all sort of a jumble
they've seen pictures in there in their
school books and stuff like that but but
to the extent that you can put it
together and you have the authenticity
of a place like the American Museum
natural history behind it just as the
dinosaur bones are properly reference to
the latest you know knowledge we updated
our dinosaurs when we found out they
were hot-blooded and I can pull up the
tail of the t-rex and redo the exhibit
is that that that that layout of the
universe and the behavior of the
universe that we're showing you is up is
up to date of the latest knowledge and
so that you hopefully we're relating it
to you in such a way that you know it it
pervades the importance of it it's just
that we see the Sun come up every day
and go down farmers know it has a lot to
do with growing their crops and so forth
then at night it's as we can't see
anything as it's dark and you see the
Stars and the moon
before we had cities and so that we
understand we're sort of in this
relationship but to show you that and
also to bridge from like the astronauts
who went to the moon we could see the
earth rising above the lunar landscape
essentially right that the moon went
from being a celestial object being
landscape where the earth was suddenly a
celestial object is that we can
emphasize that and we can amplify that
insofar as our visual journey taking you
out it's it's authentic it's backed up
by the data and and so it's a it's as
close to real as we can depict it that's
so cool Carter what you do for a living
is is really amazing in some ways what
you what you show us is realer than real
we can see the universe better than we
can see with our own senses which is
kind of crazy we could talk to you all
day it's it's so interesting
unfortunately we're basically out of
time here oh yeah I know I would like to
invite you guys when your mind through
the universe they play with the Mars
band we put together a group of
musicians to actually fly over Mars
as we do this because we have so much
information yeah I'm there all right on
that note thank you so much for
listening
this has been Startalk Allstars I'm
David Grinspoon with Chuck nice and our
guest Carter Emmert until next time
thank you this is Startalk
[Music]